let me ask you about jordan peterson you
had a great conversation with him yeah
um he has a complicated and nuanced view
of faith or faith period
um he has said that he believes in jesus
the person and the myth and
the some of the the full richness and
complexity that you've talked about
but he's surprised by his faith he's not
sure what to make of it yeah he's almost
like meta struggling with what the heck
is faith means he's a super powerful
intellect that can't compute
the faith that he's experiencing so
uh what are some interesting differences
between the two of you or some
commonalities
uh in terms of your understanding of
faith
he's a very interesting guy i've had a
couple conversations with him and i do
think he's he's moving in the direction
of of faith and his lectures in the
bible are very fine i think uh he
reminds me of the church fathers because
the church fathers would have looked at
the they call it the moral sense of the
scripture peterson probably called the
psychological meaning but i think he's
doing a lot of that
he
as i read him and talk to him i think
he's kind of at a kantian level in
regard to jesus what i mean there is
for kant jesus it's not so much the
historical jesus this figure from long
ago it's jesus as an archetype of the
moral life
you know he says he's the image of the
person perfectly pleasing to god and so
jesus inhabits our kind of moral
imagination as a as a heuristic as a as
a a goal that we're tending toward but
the historical person of jesus for
conflict well let's not fuss about that
so much it's this figure
and as i read peterson especially and
talk to him i think he's kind of there
with
the archetype of jesus and even language
of like live as though
god exists that's the outs all above
kant you know the kind of as if um
attitude and where i oppress him when we
talk is in the direction of no that's
not christianity yet i mean that's
enlightenment uh moral philosophy
but christianity is very interested in
this historical figure and very
interested that god really became one of
us and he's not just an archetype of the
moral life
he's someone he's a person
who's invaded our world and gone all the
way to the bottom of sin and thereby
saved us you know so the facticity of
jesus and the resurrection so like
peterson will talk about the
resurrection as a as a myth and all that
and you can find that in different
cultures etc but i
christianity um is saying something else
so in christianity when we're talking
about who is jesus it's not just an
archetype right it's not just a myth
it's a historical figure and the very
grounded fact
that god became one of us right is
fundamental to this idea what it what
christianity is what it means to be a
christian it's the uh
the sin and the love that came here
down to earth
means we can be one with god so that's
essential it's not just
that's right
you know it always strikes me
the difference between let's say mythic
expressions and the new testament is
it read someone like you know carl jung
and then joseph campbell whom he
influenced and then now jordan peterson
was very jungian and this sort of
archetypal reading of the scriptures and
great i mean i think it's very
interesting and there's a lot going on
there
there's a sort of calmness though about
it like yeah the interesting and that's
in this culture and that culture and
it's the form of the moral life and i
understand all that
then you read the new testament
uh whatever those people are talking
about it's not that
they are
grabbing you by the shoulders
and shaking you to get your attention to
tell you about something that happened
to them right
like the resurrection you know that the
myth of the dying and rising god and how
powerful that is and shaping our
consciousness that's fascinating that's
not the new testament the testament is
did you hear did you jesus of nazareth
whom they put to death god raised him
from the dead and he was seen by 500 and
he was seen by by peter and and and and
then lastly i saw him that's how paul
talks it's it's not the detached
you know um uh psychologist musing on
archetypal things and i think that makes
a huge difference when it comes to
christianity the intensity of the
historical details are
essential here so if you
you know if you look at
hitler and nazi germany it's not enough
to say well power corrupts and sometimes
so looking at the archetype of hitler
it's much much more important much more
powerful to look at the details of how
he came to power yeah what are the ways
he did evil onto the world and then then
you can get really intense about your
struggle with some of the complexities
of human nature and power on
institutions and all that kind of stuff
so the historical nature of the bible
we're a historical religion and we've
been is important we generate
philosophical reflection we can find
common ground with archetypal thinking
and all that we can and the church
fathers use the greek philosophy and
aquinas uses aristotle and all that's
great but we're an historical religion
and that matters immensely
you